we're gonna play a little game I call my
first time Oh sounds very saucy and
invasive the first movie you ever saw
was the big one that sticks out in my
head as I remember going to see Greece
in the theater and I thought well that's
it
I need heels and tight pants that was
that was my takeaway not like the music
the relationships I was like I have to
get me some tight pants and heels
Speight I was like to get a man but man
have to change myself and that's that's
why we're here today that's what we want
to teach young yeah the first r-rated
movie you ever saw
I snuck downstairs while my parents were
watching Carrie we had doors that opened
up so I hid behind a door and I was just
watching carry through the crack in the
door and I got real freaked out I was
too scared to go back upstairs so I just
stayed there watching it and I watched
the whole movie and I just was quietly
sobbing behind the if my parents really
watching the movie the first movie that
you related to and had a real effect on
you there's something about planes
trains and automobiles that I just
remember feeling crazy because I was
laughing so hard and then the next
second was crying
I feel crazy pillows that whole movies
perfect it's perfect when was the first
time you realized you were funny
my family's funny we sat around the
kitchen table every night and had dinner
together and it was always kind of like
who could who and we were just telling
stories from the day but like I remember
feeling kind of like proud if I told the
story from my day I'm like everybody
laugh what was it like the first time
they direct a cold action on the bus
kind of crazy because I was producing it
as well and you know we kind of got
sucked into the vortex so of getting it
getting it started and getting it going
I always have a weird word or phrase
that gets me into what the characters
voice and I didn't have it and I thought
I remember looking at Ben and going and
I don't I had I don't know what she
sounds like
then we did one take where I finally
felt like my I finally felt like I
dropped into it mm-hmm
it's gonna be okay do you have a word
now that you use our digital characters
come to time soon Dave bedwood make me
do her laughs when she goes like ah
which later Kristen Bell was always like
you sound like elf what was the first
time that you remember thinking I'm
successful
every time I wrap anything there's a
little there's a probably 70% of me
that's like well it was a good run I'll
never work again I mean just to my core
I always am like well I'll go back to
Illinois and probably I don't know plant
corn or something I just always think
like that's it the fact that we were
like we should write stuff and make
movies at some point somebody should be
like you're nuts but look where we are
I know it's amazing thank you so much
Melissa for sharing it your first time
with me yes I appreciate it I'll never
forget it
[Music]